جدد الجيش التركي قسمه صباح اليوم على عده
نقاط بمدينه كوباني عين العرب شمال شرقي
سوريا وبحسب مصادر كرديه في القصف هذه
المره كان جويا ومنفعيا وتركز على تله
المطله على مدينه كوباني من الجهه
الجنوبيه للمدينه اضافه الى ثلاث صواريخ
او ثلاثه صواريخ على غربي المدينه وكان
الطائرات الحربيه التركيه والمدفعيه قد
قصفت مواقع كرديه في عده مناطق الشماليه
سوريا وشمال العراق اسفر عن وقوع نحو 31
قتيلا بينهم عدد من المدنيين في عمليه
اشرف عليها وزير الدفاع التركيه خلصي على
كار بنفسه فيما وصفت الاداره الذاتيه
الكرديه بسوريا القصف التركي بالعدوان غير
المبرر مضيفه ان التفجير اسطنبول ما هو
الاثريه لتبريره هجوم انقره على شمال وشرق
سوريا بينما شدد وزير خارجيات العراق على
عدم استخدام اراضي البلاد مقرا او ممر
لتحديد امن الدول
في هذا السياق العمليه التي نفذت ضد اهداف
الارهابيه في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا منذ
منتصف الليل هذا المساء تم التخطيط لها
بحساسيه والحسن الحظ كما تنفيذها بنجاح